الشيء الذي سأعتذر عنه للاعتراف بأنني كنت
مخطئًا لأنني كنت ملحدًا
والآن كمسلم أفهم أن هذا
ليس هو الحال تمامًا
[موسيقى]
مثيرة للاهتمام هذه نقطة مثيرة للاهتمام
أثارتها للتو لأنني الآن
إسلامي وهي مضحكة لأنني
اعتدت أن تكون ملحدًا وعندما تكون
ملحدًا ، فأنت تعتقد أن الدين يسبب
مشاكل أكثر مما يحلها ، ثم
تصل إلى الإدراك وتبدأ في
معرفة حقيقة نفسك
وحقيقة الله وتدرك أن
الدين هو في الواقع.  إن علاج
معظم المشاكل في العالم
والإلحاد هو المشكلة في العالم
[الموسيقى]
نعم لأنك تتعلم وتنمو
وتتطور كما قلت في الوقت الذي
صدقته فيه لأنني لم أؤمن
بالله في  الوقت
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بما تؤمن به بالفعل
كمسلم ممارس الآن أه نعم أعتقد
أن الإسلام جميل أعتقد
أنه آخر دين حقيقي على الأرض إنه
بالتأكيد آخر دين محترم على
الأرض وشعرت بأنني مختلف  في الداخل
منذ أن تحولت وأعتقد أن
لديها حلولًا للعديد من المشكلات
التي نواجهها في العالم اليوم
[موسيقى]